[موسيقى]
هذا فيديو يظهر طائرة هليكوبتر
تابعة للمتمردين الحوثيين تقترب من
سفينة شحن في البحر الأحمر اليمنية
والأعلام الفلسطينية في الأمام والوسط بعد
هبوط الطائرة فوق السفينة الضخمة
مسلحون يرتدون
ملابس سوداء وسترات فلاك بيج يروحون ويجدون
قد
يبدو الأمر وكأنه تمرين تدريبي عالي السرعة أثناء إقلاع المروحية،
ولكن عندما يدخل المسلحون
جسر السفينة، يصبح الأمر حقيقيًا للغاية حيث
يستسلم أفراد الطاقم المرعوبون بسرعة لاحقًا داخل السفينة، ويلوح مسلح
بمسدسه ويصرخ الله أكبر الموت
للبحارة.  الموت لليهود
لإسرائيل، الحوثيون هم
مجموعة سياسية وعسكرية شيعية تدعمها إيران
وتخوض حربًا أهلية في اليمن
ضد القوات المدعومة من المملكة العربية السعودية
على الرغم من أن القتال تباطأ مؤخرًا إلى حد
الغليان منذ بدء الحرب في غزة، فقد
أطلقت المجموعة
الصواريخ بشكل متكرر  تم اعتراض جميع السفن باتجاه إسرائيل، وتم
تصوير الفيديو
ونشره من قبل المسلحين الحوثيين
أنفسهم، ومن الواضح أنهم يعتزمون إرسال
رسالة إلى أي سفن مرتبطة
بإسرائيل، حيث
أفادت العديد من وسائل الإعلام الإسرائيلية أن أحد أغنى
الأشخاص في إسرائيل، رجل الأعمال الملياردير رامي
أونار، هو مالك جزئي.
لم تستجب الشركة البريطانية المالكة للسفينة أونار
لطلب التعليق من
CNN، وقد استأجرت السفينة من قبل
شركة يابانية في
مكتب رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي، وتقول إنه لا يوجد أي من أفراد الطاقم
إسرائيليون، ولا ينبغي أن يكون أي من هذا
مفاجأة بعد  أرسل الحوثيون
خطتهم برقية قبل أسبوع، وقد
رحبت حماس بالاستيلاء على
السفينة بينما تنفي إيران أن يكون لها
أي علاقة بها، وتصفها الولايات المتحدة بأنها
انتهاك للقانون الدولي، ونطالب
بالإفراج الفوري عن السفينة
وطاقمها، السفينة الأخيرة التي غادرت  ميناء في
تركيا في طريقهم إلى الهند، لا توجد معلومات
عن سلامة الطاقم، لقد
وعد الحوثيون فقط أنهم سيعاملون
وفقًا لقيم الإسلام سكوت
ماكلين سي إن إن اسطنبول